[Music]
everyone my name is Jessie and today I'm
in testing for famous celebrity mac and
cheese recipes to see which one is
actually the best I'll be testing
recipes from Patti LaBelle Gordon Ramsay
Khloe Kardashian and I even have one
from Rihanna I measure everything out
how the recipe stated and I got three of
my friends to taste it and a blind taste
test
so which one should be the best it's
about to get cheesy first up is Patti
LaBelle she cooks her pasta in salted
water with a bit of oil drains it then
returns it to the pot in a large bowl
combine shredded Muenster both mild and
sharp cheddar and Monterey Jack cheese
add some half-and-half to the pasta
along Kube Velveeta cheese melted butter
and mix it in and even more cheese keep
stirring it and season with season salt
pepper and kosher salt transfer it into
a prepared baking casserole dish and
topped with more cheese and a few dots
of butter bake until nice and bubbly and
sir we have some browning over here
which is exciting we had a nice texture
[Music]
there's some beautiful pockets of cheese
like just creamy it's actually delicious
very cheesy reminds me of kraft mac and
cheese but i do enjoy it
it has nothing on top i'm no pepper
flakes like nothing is going on to make
me say this is some real sexy mac and
cheese
this is boring up next it's khloe
kardashian she starts by cooking
macaroni in salted water into el dente
and drains it heat some butter until
melted then whisk in some flour and cook
for about two minutes
add some milk and whisk until thickened
and this is where it gets kind of weird
you're gonna chop up some American
cheese add it straight to the sauce then
add some shredded cheddar still until
melted and paprika and egg yolks and
whisk even more add the pasta back in
and stir it so coats grab a mini muffin
pan brush with butter and sprinkle with
some crumbs on cheese spoon they're
prepared mac and cheese into it top it's
even more parmesan and you're gonna bake
these until sizzling pop them out and
these little guys are done it looks like
I can take this down in one bite mac and
cupcake I like this one
presentation-wise like okay yeah it's
cute but I feel bamboozled with the
amount I'm getting this one's alright
you got a good macaroni - cheese ratio
if I went to the grocery store and I
walk by one of little machines with the
toys in it and one of the toys was the
plastic mac and cheese toy that I could
get for 25 cents that's what I'm chewing
up right now next up is Gordon Ramsay he
cooks cauliflower and salted water until
tender he fishes it out drops in a bowl
ice water to print it from cooking any
further then he had some macaroni
straight to that pot of cauliflower
water and cooks it until tender he
drains it and he mixes it with the
cooked cauliflower and a few knobs of
butter and lets that melt in put that
aside heat some butter in a pan and add
flour and mustard powder to make a roux
gradually add some milk so it thickens
up and keep whisking until it gets nice
and thick see some cayenne pepper and
salt in a bowl mix three cheese's
together cheddar Lincolnshire and
Cheshire
as those back into the sauce and stir it
until melted add the cooked macaroni and
cauliflower mix it up to coke and spread
that into a large baking dish and smooth
it out on top
combine the extra cheese with some fresh
breadcrumbs and thyme and sprinkle that
right on top bake until nice and golden
and that's about it we got some like ol
Krusty's on here little Christ to it the
crunchy stuff is delicious I think it
could be cheesier all right that's good
tastes like a fluffy cloud
you would get a little slice of heaven I
do like the way to this taste I don't
know what's on it it's got the mac and
cheese with a twist it might be
cauliflower someone importantly this mac
and cheese eating this mac and cheese is
like eating a great steak this is like
Miss Congeniality American cheese they
help people out
but it did not necessarily give enough
to win the crown of the best mac and
cheese up next is rihanna chick hooks
macaroni in boiling water then drinks it
place it back on the stove and add
grated white onion julienned bell pepper
and some sliced spring onions and mix
that all in next and a quarter cup of
ketchup and mustard as well as some
spicy scotch bonnet pepper sauce to mix
that all in and a handful of shredded
Colby jack cheese at a time stirring
until melted and add some water if it
gets too thick once it's the right
consistency garnish with some more
spring onions and that's it
it looks cheesy as hell this is a rope
that's David I'm real strong in here the
whole pepper the action that's happening
they are making it an exciting
experience I taste the peppers it's
actually pretty hot closing my throat up
a little bit there was some love put
into making this mac and cheese stand
out from the rest
I definitely pass on this which
celebrity is the best mac and cheese
recipe let's find that and of all the
celebrity mac and cheese
think my favorite would have to be
number three mainly because the addition
with the cauliflower made it just stand
out from all the rest wasn't overly
cheesy and I'm not kidding when I say I
can compare it to a great steak Mansell
always coming in at the last minute I
liked number one the best it was like
the right types of cheese it was a
cockatoo like gooey cheese perfect
comfort
mac and cheese hey LaBelle oh yeah the
one that I can say stood out the most to
me number four they had some color in
there it was spice kick to it it was a
different take corner that's we're gonna
make sense so I heard I'm the tiebreaker
for the celebrity mac and cheese let's
go this one's colorful all right this
one I don't really like peppers I guess
so I feel like you shouldn't put too
much extra [ __ ] and mac and cheese it
sounds good there's different types of
cheeses in this one I just want either
this was my favor on there you have it
Corner Ramsay is the best mac and cheese
[Music]